ah
[Música]
al link inocencia y florentina
ellas son tres empleadas domésticas
nacidas en filipinas pero yo las conocí
en singapur las conocí en la ong a la
que asisten para luchar por sus derechos
porque en singapur la ley para empleadas
domésticas no está muy hecha como para
cumplirse y si se cumple tampoco es que
tenga tantos privilegios
en esta ong además de ir a buscar que
las respeten como seres humanos también
van a buscar conexión a internet
cuando las visite escuché cómo caían las
notificaciones una tras de otra los
mensajes de whatsapp que no terminas de
escuchar el sonido cuando ya cabe otro
atrás como nos pasa a nosotros a veces
cuando volvemos de vacaciones o cuando
pasamos un tiempo sin conectarnos
una de ellas link que está sentada en
las fotos pidió para usar la computadora
que tiene en el lugar para hacer una
llamada a través de skype
después de que terminó con todos esos
mensajes de whatsapp arregló para verse
con alguien a través de videollamada
que estaba en su país de nacimiento
cuando se sentó del otro lado de la
pantalla aparecieron dos niños un nene y
una nena que supongo que eran sus hijos
o sus sobrinos o unos niños que forman
parte de su familia
lin empezó a hablar durante unos
segundos
y al poco tiempo desconecto el vídeo
y dijo a través del micrófono que la
conexión no daba que la velocidad no
alcanzaba para poder verse y también
conversar
verlo fue un poco raro porque no había
sido la conexión la que se cayó había
sido link la que desconectó la cámara
pasaron unos segundos más
y lin también desconecto el audio y
cortó la llamada
lo inmediatamente posterior a cortar la
llamada
fue que el link se pusiera a llorar
desconsoladamente por varios minutos sin
que se entendiera mucho
en realidad ella lo soluciono
mandándonos whatsapp diciendo que la
conexión era realmente muy mala y no
daban ni siquiera para una llamada
pero la realidad del link es la de
muchas empleadas domésticas que trabajan
en singapur que no nacieron en ese país
y que están ahí por la diferencia de
salarios que logran con las que
mantienen a veces una a veces tres
familias la realidad de estas personas
como link incluye prácticamente no tener
derechos hay mujeres que llegan a esta
ong a pedir ayuda porque en los lugares
donde trabajan además de no tener
internet ninguna a veces les niegan la
privacidad las obligan a dormir en el
piso les restringen la comida y algunas
hasta les pegan
hay una historia de una de las mujeres
que se tiró por el balcón de la casa en
la que trabajaba para salir corriendo a
pedir ayuda esta ong porque literalmente
no aguantaba más
a estas mujeres las visité en un viaje
por el mundo que hice durante más de
tres años junto a mi hermano en el que
visité 30 países de varios continentes
nuestro viaje no era un viaje
especialmente turístico y la historia
que recién les conté es una muestra de
ellos buscábamos también ese lado ve esa
otra cara esa faceta diferente que cada
destino tenía para ofrecernos
durante el viaje entendimos que en la
vida aprendemos una cosa y es que
existen dos lados el nuestro y el malo
le voy a poner un ejemplo que
seguramente a muchos los que estamos acá
nos pasó supongamos que vamos en un auto
paramos en un semáforo y del otro lado
una persona se acerca y nos ofrece
limpiarnos el parabrisas a cambio de una
moneda
oa veces ni siquiera eso a veces
directamente nos pide una moneda
nosotros que vamos adentro
pensamos que quizás estamos bien
pero también pensamos que podríamos
estar mejor si esta gente en lugar de
vivir de los planes que nosotros
financiamos con nuestros impuestos
tuvieran más hábitos de trabajo no
fueran tan vagos y en lugar de venir a
mendigar hicieran lo que hacemos
nosotros trabajar
pero del otro lado
la persona quizá está mal
y piensa que podría estar mejor si no
fuera por nosotros que lo tenemos todo
que no lo compartimos que los oprimimos
con nuestro sistema y que no somos
capaces ni siquiera de bajar la ventana
para compartirles un poco de lo que nos
sobra
cada uno tiene su lado y los dos ven en
el otro lado malo
viajar durante estos tres años nos
permitió
olvidarnos de esos lados en nuestro país
por eso decidimos volver a uruguay y
recorrer los 19 departamentos en 6 meses
para conocer a nuestra gente
y quisimos hacerlo como lo hicimos en
otras partes del mundo a nuestra forma
humildes haciendo dedo pidiéndole a
familias desconocidas que nos abrieran
su casa que nos hicieran un lugar en
alguna cama en algún colchón en algún
sillón o a veces directo en el piso
tuvimos la suerte de que alguien nos
prestará un auto entonces no pudimos
hacer dedo y lo que hicimos fue una
técnica que nosotros bautizamos de dow a
la inversa que voy a tratar de
explicarla nosotros íbamos por la ruta y
en uruguay casi nadie hace dedo entonces
parábamos en las paradas de ómnibus
bajamos la ventana y le decíamos a la
gente a dónde íbamos y que teníamos
lugares libres por si alguien se quería
subir
la gente se miraba un poco extrañada y
es raro que alguien se acerque a
ofrecerte que le pidas algo
quieres pedirme un favor
mucha gente se miraba incómoda y no
aceptaba pero no fue el caso de marta y
de tito que se miraron extrañados pero
sí aceptaron la vez que le ofrecimos
llevarlos a ellos y vamos para salto
marta y tito viven pasando salto
entonces los tuvimos que dejar en la
terminal para que completaran el tramo
que le faltaba para llegar
durante el viaje le fuimos contando de
nuestro viaje por el mundo de nuestro
viaje por uruguay de nuestra forma de
viajar y de ver la vida
y les pareció interesante y nos
ofrecieron desde la humildad como lo
hizo casi todo el mundo
que si queríamos los visitaremos en
belén el pueblo del que ellos son
habitantes en belén no hay ninguna
atracción turista ninguna atracción
turística no hay nada que de verdad te
pueda motivar a llegar hasta ahí
salvo que marta y dota inviten
entonces estuvimos ahí varias noches y
en algún momento son tantas las personas
que nos cruzamos tantas la gente que nos
escribió por redes sociales para
aconsejarnos que conozcamos distintas
cosas de uruguay que no sabemos bien
cuándo
alguien nos recomendó visitar una cárcel
al principio
decidimos que no porque tendríamos
nosotros interés en visitar una cárcel
hasta que nos explicaron que era una
cárcel un poco diferente algo así como
una cárcel del modelo una cárcel sin
rejas una cárcel sin celdas una cárcel
en la que los presos viven con sus
familias una cárcel en las que a veces
hay un policía porque el patrullero
también se usa para llevar personas del
pueblo a lugares a los que el transporte
no accede así que a veces en esa cárcel
los presos también están libres
pero nosotros íbamos a conocer la cárcel
y no los presos
porque aprendimos que en la vida hay dos
lados el nuestro y el malo y claramente
ellos no estaban de nuestro lado
hasta que conocimos al vano alba no es
el preso barra encargado del tambo de
esta cárcel y nos contó su historia
entre llantos y risas mucho más entre
llantos que entre risas al vano nos
contó por más de una hora muchas de las
cosas que vivió
al vano se mandó una grande esta
hace más de 10 años preso y todavía
tiene para varios años más
nunca trato de convencernos de que fuera
injusto que él estuviera preso y
nosotros nunca nos convencimos de eso
pero si nos hizo sentir que estaba listo
para reinsertarse que había entendido el
error que cometió y que cuando la
condena terminara iba a salir para no
volver
entonces entramos a la cárcel
entendiendo que en la vida hay dos lados
el nuestro y el de albano
pero alba no se quería cambiar de lado y
cada vez entendíamos menos
siguiendo nuestra recorrida conocimos el
hogar los tulipanes que es un hogar que
da asistencia a personas con
discapacidad las 24 horas del día los
365 días del año
la misión del hogar es asistencia y
contención pero cuando decimos dar
asistencia dar contención no se entiende
muy bien qué es asistencia puede ser
apoyo médico contención puede ser que
alguien venga y toque música o les
enseñe a cantar o baile con ellos pero
en los tulipanes no hay presupuestos ni
recursos para hacer algo tan sofisticado
en los tulipanes dar contención es dar
contención abrazar mimar escuchar apoyar
estar ahí hacer sentir a las personas
queridas hacer sentir a las personas que
existen el 80% de los muchachos que
están en los tulipanes
no tienen a nadie
algunos los más afortunados dentro de
este 80 por ciento que no tiene a nadie
tiene
gente que en las fechas festivas y en
sus cumpleaños lo llaman por teléfono
pero está el caso de una chica que nos
contó mariza que era su cumpleaños y las
horas pasaban y ya lejos de soñar con
que alguien la viniera a visitar veían
que el teléfono no sonaba
y en la tarde-noche se acercó a la
oficina de dirección donde está marisa y
le dijo marisa yo nací de un zapallo que
nadie me llama
hasta ahora lo cuento y me cuesta seguir
hablando porque cuando entramos ahí
sentimos que
la gente de los tulipanes no tiene a
nadie pero la historia que nos contó
mariza nos hizo entender que hay gente
ahí que no tiene a nadie
pero no solo recorrimos lugares también
dimos charlas en escuelas en los 19
departamentos de nuestro país recorrimos
escuelas y liceos para contarles a los
chicos sobre nuestro sueño de viajar
sobre cómo fue hacerlo realidad
pero sobre todo a contar la historia del
mundo y de nuestro país para tratar de
que no ignoren a las personas con las
que viven para tratar de que no aprendan
lo que los adultos terminamos
aprendiendo
recorrimos estas escuelas
con la idea de olvidarnos esto que se
aprende que en la vida hay dos lados el
nuestro y el malo
estar tres años afuera nos ayudó a poder
vivir de esta manera
pero también es una cuestión de actitud
cuando viajamos 15 días algunos 20
algunos afortunados durante un mes en
nuestras vacaciones
no sabemos de qué lado están las
personas con las que interactuamos no
logramos encasillar los de nuestro lado
o del lado malo y por eso además de
pasarla espectacular
tenemos experiencias y conocemos gente
maravillosa
si le ponemos esa actitud a nuestra vida
en nuestro país los momentos
espectaculares no se van a reducir a 15
días a los 1 mes sino a todo el año
y la gente maravillosa que conozcamos
además va a ser nuestra gente
porque quizá
las empleadas domésticas de filipinas y
los que tenemos el privilegio de ver
nuestros derechos básicos respetados y
garantizados
quizás no tengamos que estar en lados
diferentes
quizás la gente de los tulipanes y los
que tenemos la suerte de que alguien nos
llame para nuestro cumpleaños
no tenemos que estar en lado diferentes
quizás los lados son
fruto de nuestra imaginación de nuestras
cabezas y sobre todo nuestros prejuicios
y quizás si fuimos nosotros los que lo
construimos
podamos romperlos y estar un poco más
juntos
ojalá lo hagamos gracias
ah